the acting capital police chief is
apologizing for security failures during
the assault
on a capital saying they should have
been better prepared
for violence all this comes as president
biden directs law enforcement to study
the urgent threat
of domestic extremism in the wake of
that attack
according to one recent analysis white
supremacist groups and far-right
extremists conducted
67 percent of u.s terror attacks and
plots in the first eight months of the
last year
examples you may recall include a car
attack at a black lives matter protest
in virginia
and plans to kidnap michigan governor
gretchen whitmer
the number of right-wing attacks and
plots has more than doubled since 2014.
former homeland security secretary
michael chertoff joins us now
secretary chertoff good morning to you
this year we will mark the somber
20th anniversary of the 9 11 attacks a
moment in our history that led to
significant security changes at airports
in surveillance in intelligence in the
way we fight
overseas terrorism what do we need to do
now
to fight what many people despite the
lack of a law are calling domestic
terrorism
well i think it is domestic terrorism
and i think we need to treat it as
seriously as we have been treating
global jihadism
in terms of a threat to homeland
security so the first step is to very
aggressively investigate
the people who committed an insurrection
at the capitol
on january 6th because that's going to
lead you to a number of groups
which have espoused violence or other
kinds of disruption
beyond that i think we need to think
carefully about how do we
monitor what is going on over the
internet
to detect threats
so we've gotten into it really quickly
here the key phrase is
seriously investigate and monitor we
have laws allowing law enforcement to do
that when the threat is foreign
when the threat is domestic you run into
constitutional issues because a group
may be
saying things that are poisonous but
they are protected perhaps by the first
amendment
how does law enforcement navigate that
very difficult terrain
well that's exactly right it is very
challenging domestically
because not only do you have laws about
search and seizure and wiretapping
that are more restrictive here but there
is a concern about chilling legitimate
political speech
but let's remember incitement to
violence is not political speech
and i think we need to look carefully at
what the line is
between what is protected and perhaps
disturbing speech
and what is unprotected violent speech
when people are planning
or urging acts of violence against
public officials or
against minority groups that is not
really protected speech and i think we
need to be a little bit more
pragmatic about how we apply these rules
one thing we know for certain right now
mr secretary is that nobody
associated with the assault on the
capital will be charged as a domestic
terrorist there is no criminal statute
in this country with that category
should that change and if it changes how
will that help law enforcement
well first of all there are a lot of
statutes that can be applied it's not
necessarily true that you have to apply
something called domestic terrorism
we also by the way have hate crime laws
which could be used in some of these
circumstances
the question about passing a domestic
terrorism law is
does it really add anything and again we
don't want to go so far as to
criminalize
unpopular ideas so i would take it
slowly
and i wouldn't rush to pass something i
would recognize there are existing laws
that prohibit violent activity
such as what we've seen including
sedition
and then as we see whether these laws
are adequate
decide whether we need to tweak them in
order to embrace things
that are now emerging as real threats
yeah secretary trudeau i'm interested in
why you say take it slowly
because although president biden has
only just recently
directed the fbi and the department of
homeland security
to assess and come up with a plan to
fight domestic terrorism
the rise in domestic terrorism has been
recognized by all of those organizations
already there's been a tripling i
believe in the number of
attacks since the 90s according to data
collected by an organization at west
point
so why go slow given that we have seen
this there is consensus that it's an
issue
uh it's not a new concept isn't it time
to act
well let me be clear i think we should
be very energetic
in investigating and prosecuting people
who are committing these crimes
and we should treat it as a high
priority in terms of
the investigation and in terms of
monitoring within the law
what i'm saying though is in terms of
new criminal statutes
we ought to go slowly before we put
something in place
that winds up in a year or two getting a
negative reaction
after 9 11 understandably we put a
number of measures in place including
measures on collection of intelligence
and and communications that subsequently
got some real pushback a couple of years
later
because people said you overreacted so
this to me is a question of calibrating
to get what you need but make making
sure you're respecting the boundaries
of what is protected political speech
while we have you i want to get you on
one other delicate constitutional
private public question which is
social media they are attempting to
police hate speech
uh and speech from white supremacists
and related right-wing extremists
how do they strike the balance should
they be banning widely
uh what would your recommendation be
i think the social media companies have
stepped up and being more energetic
about not just labeling but actually
shutting down incitement and violent
speech
the reality is the first amendment
applies to the government
private platforms like newspapers
have the right to manage what it appears
for their readers and i think most of
these companies
understand that if you have violent
imagery
or incitement you're going over the line
of their terms of use
and over the line of what's appropriate
so i
do think that by and large the platforms
are moving in the
right direction again we don't want to
overreact
but i don't think there's a right to get
out there and urge
violence under any theory of free speech
yeah it's a fascinating conversation i'd
like to say it's only intellectual but
lives
are at stake as we speak so it's good
that
there is a swift and energetic as you
say effort to get on top of it michael
chertoff thank you very much